[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNA RYS: TurboTranslations
is a website
where you can order fast,
professional, people-powered
translation 24/7, so
whenever you need it
and whenever you
need it quickly.
GRZESIEK MIKLASZEWSKI:
TurboTranslations
is built on Ruby on
Rails web technology.
At first it was built in PHP.
It was a little project like
a prototype, a very basic
prototype, and then we
rewrite it to Ruby on Rails.
Ruby on Rails is a
good technology tool
for fast prototyping.
In startups,
especially, you have
to see if different things
work or not-- landing
pages, some [? pivots, ?] some
features that are not actually
working, but clients
think they are working,
and you can promote them.
In Ruby on Rails, you can
fastly develop such features.
And if it works, it's OK.
We can develop it later.
If not, we can just remove the
code and start another one.
ANNA RYS: We're planning to
expand our startup, starting
with Europe, for two
reasons, basically.
One of them is that we're
here and we know the market.
And it's just easier for us to
go to France, even personally,
and talk to the customers
there, as opposed
to going to the US or Asia.
And the other reason is that
all of competition is in the US
and in Asia.
So that's something we would
like to avoid, you know?
It's really important
to our clients
that they see that there's
a face behind what's
happening to their text.
They don't want to
send it to a machine
and not be sure it's
going to be good enough.
I mean, we do believe that one
day-- maybe 10, maybe 15, maybe
20 years from now-- let's
say Google Translate will
be good enough to cover 90% of
translation needs worldwide.
But there will always
be translations
that need to be done by humans.
And our clients
really appreciate
that we communicate
with them personally
and that the translators also
do that and that they actually
see that there are people behind
this product and not machines.